The tactical genius, Muhammad Hijab,
came up with yet another brilliant plan.
He decided to start going live on his
channel and inviting Christians to
debate him.
The first episode did not go according
to plan because God Logic pulled up and
absolutely destroyed him. And I'm not
exaggerating. I was filming at the Quran
Demolition Ranch when I started getting
messages about Avery embarrassing Hijab.
But I didn't know how bad Avery was
embarrassing him until we went through
it, not in the zot sense, during some
live streams.
This was as bad as the infamous holes in
the narrative interview where Muhammad
Hijab got Sheikh Yasir Qadhi to admit
that Muslim scholars can't explain all
the different versions of the Quran.
Remember that discussion?
Yasir Qadhi was basically begging Hijab
to stop exposing the Quran.
The issue of ahruf and preservation and
qira'at and relationships between them,
these are very, very difficult issues.
And
the most advanced of our scholars,
they're not quite fully certain how to
solve all of the unanswered questions in
there. Here's the point.
These issues should only be discussed
amongst people who know what the qira'at
are and who understand some of these
questions. You add to that very
well-known issues of I don't even want
to be explicit. Then you bring on top of
that makhutat. And then and that. And
it's very clear to you and to every
single very advanced student and
specialist that the standard narrative
has holes in it. That's what I'm going
to say. The standard narrative does not
answer some very pressing questions. But
Hijab wouldn't listen because he's a
complete, utter, total narcissist. So,
the myth of perfect preservation was
obliterated. The comment section was
flooded with Muslims saying that the
interview was making them doubt Islam.
Hijab cut out and deleted the Quran
discussion from the live stream, which
only drew more attention to it. Then
Hijab and Yasir Qadhi both deleted the
entire interview, which drew even more
attention to what happened.
Later, when we posted clips of the
interview, Yasir Qadhi started filing
false copyright complaints to force us
to take down our videos. But we won
because fair use.
It was all downhill for Hijab after
that. Last year, he was exposed for
treating Muslim women like prostitutes.
One of his many ex-wives came forward
and told the world how he operates. He
promised her that if she became one of
his wives, they would have a life
together, a home together, a family
together.
But after they consummated the marriage,
he told her that he only wanted her for
sex in hotels. She exposed him for this,
and Hijab and dozens of his fellow Dawah
gandhists declared war on this woman.
They lied about her. They photoshopped
screenshots to attack her. Hijab even
posted a fake AI confession from her. It
was evil and pathetic. These Dawah guys
treat Muslim women worse than they would
treat dogs, and you know what they think
about dogs.
Then Hijab lost his frivolous lawsuit
against Douglas Murray. The judge was so
disgusted by Hijab's lies that he wrote
in his ruling,
"I am satisfied that he lied on
significant issues with the consequence
that his evidence overall is worthless."
Yes, a UK court has confirmed that
Muhammad Hijab is such a massive liar
that any evidence he presents is
worthless.
You know what's also worthless?
Hijab's word.
Hijab has zero integrity, which is weird
because in his interview with Jordan
Peterson, he boasted about how Muslims
keep their word. The Muslims are on
their conditions.
>> that mean? To abide by your word.
>> You have to stick by your words. No
matter for us, if you don't stick to
your words, then this shows a lack of
character.
>> But that wasn't Avery's experience with
Muhammad Hijab. Avery asked for verbal
consent that he could post the debate on
his channel.
And he asked for verbal consent that
Hijab wouldn't file a copyright
complaint. Here's the clip. So, is it
okay that I record this and put it on my
channel? Just want to get a verbal
confirmation. We're good? Well, I mean,
look, you can go live right now. I mean,
I haven't got any issues with that
myself. Yeah, I'm recording. I thought
you were live already. Yeah, I'm
recording right now. So, I'm just making
sure I can
>> live. Go live so that your people can
see what's happening right now.
>> they they will. So, I I just want a
verbal confirmation you're not going to
copyright strike me.
No, you're good. You're going to go live
and it's absolutely fine. Okay, cool.
All right, awesome. Hijab gave verbal
consent.
And what happened?
The debate started going viral on
Avery's channel because Christians were
loving every minute of it.
Hijab challenged Christians to a battle
of wits, but he was completely unarmed.
So, what did Hijab do? Take his loss
like a man? Of course not. He's a
narcissist. So, instead of honoring his
word like a man, he filed a false
copyright complaint against Avery.
Hijab lost so bad, he broke his word,
abused YouTube's copyright system, and
got Avery a copyright strike.
But Muslims honor their agreements,
right? In fact, one of the signs, one of
the signs of a hypocrite
is that he goes against a religious
hypocrite is that he is a
if he if he makes a contract, he goes
against it. It seems as of the most
despicable things. Hijab was probably
following the example of Orthodox Muslim
who bragged about doing the same thing
to another Christian. After getting
embarrassed in a debate with Elijah
Johnson, Orthodox Lips filed a copyright
complaint and then bragged about it. He
posted,
"How I feel when I intellectually
dominate a Christian apologist. Post him
embarrassing." You can't spell
embarrassing? Pretty embarrassing, but
to be fair, you're a master of spelling
compared to your fake prophet.
"Post him embarrassing himself and
copyright strike him and take away his
paycheck."
So, this is the new dawah tactic.
Actually, it's not new. Years ago,
Muhammad Hijab told Adam Saleh to file a
copyright complaint against AP when AP
appeared on his show. Okay. Get ready.
He's going to post tweets right now and
talk like a lot of a lot of crap. He's
going to talk about
>> him permission to put his this up on his
channel as well.
I didn't give him no permission, but I'm
going to I'm
>> it. I'll copyright strike the the guy
who tries it, [laughter] man. Yeah, no.
I don't know. I I don't know if he's
going to play anything, but I'm pretty
sure he's going to try to upload
something. So, If you don't copyright
strike him straight away, man.
But notice, Hijab asked if they had
given permission to AP. He's going to
talk about I gave him permission to put
his this up on his channel as well.
I didn't give him no permission, but I'm
going to I'm
>> it. I'll copyright strike the the guy
who
>> [laughter]
>> tries it, man. So, Hijab apparently
thought permission was relevant.
But now, in 2026, he thinks it's
perfectly acceptable to give permission
and then file a false copyright
complaint anyway.
Welcome to dawah in 2026. I'm posting
this as a warning. These guys are
chronic compulsive liars who have no
honor or integrity, who don't believe
they have to adhere to any agreements
they make with you and who are
constantly looking for new ways to
deceive you.
Dawah is deception.
Don't trust anything these lying clowns
say, ever.
They worship a god who brags about being
the best of deceivers and they worship a
prophet who declared war is deceit.
Lying is like breathing to them.
But it looks like people are catching
on.
Thanks for proving our point yet again,
hijab.
Now we get to introduce you to a little
thing called the Streisand effect.
That's where someone's pathetic attempts
to hide something
end up drawing more attention to it.
>> [music]
[music]
>> But maybe Allah only made it appear that
hijab gave consent.